thank you very much pleasure to be here
god save the queen it's nice to be here
in your country don't if you know this
in my country the movie 8 mile was
retitled 12 point 9 kilometers an hour
scene 8 mile is the charts the rise of
Eminem through Detroit's battle rap
scene and obviously I relate to that do
may not see me I'm a pretty pretty
badass rapper I am I know that that's
slightly undermined by the fact that
I've got chamomile tea on stage with me
but I didn't think about that it's tasty
I am a rapper I'm a freestyle rapper I
make up raps on the spot basically you
have to decide what you want to hear a
rap about and then I'll do a rap about
those things there are three rules on
the suggestions number one no food
number 2 no animals the most common
things your brains think over the most
common suggestions I get I don't like
taking the same suggestions twice
there's not as fun third rule nothing
too obvious don't say brexit or trump or
anything like that it makes it boring
don't be too sexual and gross the best
suggestion anyone ever said was
ninth-century crop rotation
you can aim for those lofty Peaks so
let's get some suggestions from you guys
I'll come to this side first what you
want to hear a rap about skydiving cool
with your skydive is that the correct
past tense
have you skydive have you skydived I
know you're all look at me go your
English Chris figure out how you man
abhi you invented the language boy yeah
I did I did yeah
you guys went yesterday with it just the
two of you with a three and one didn't
make it
skydiving cool terrifying very brave I
commend you guys over here the crusade
someone suggested the Crusades last
night were you here so yeah someone
suggested it stop messing around me what
you shine puberty amazing I mean I don't
know anything about that cuz I cannot
grow a beard just mainly cuz I don't
have a chin so puberty puberty
that's nice puberty skydiving back of
the room what you want to hear run back
then you know the back of the room and
you broke a rule that's an animal gosh
that was aggressive I'm sorry need more
chamomile calm me down so what did you
say so earthquakes we're at about last
night cuz it happened while we were on
stage it was horrible wine tasting what
did you say so was it large toes due to
bad blood circulation
wine-tasting skydiving
what was your puberty and large toes due
to bad blood circulation bowel do-right
less some less to this Jonah drop that
beat this is a freestyle that's a rat
made up on the spot
based entirely on those suggestions not
if it's prepared not if it's rehearsed
and do not worry it will not be anywhere
near as atrociously embarrassingly bad
as you're expecting a 29 year old
privately educated middle class white
British boy to be I see my favorite
replace I go and get a big ball and a
star the wine tastes a go to the pinot
noir not Grigio if you are a saw Melia
then please go down to my dinner party
tell me how to slip it you've got a take
about 30 seconds for you sip it
apparently you've got move around and
your head thinks a and look at the legs
that's the mark on the rim don't know
why it works oh it is so viscous what
you get in on the Pala Chris please
discuss mmm aromas of bourbon and wood
when it comes to taste in my palates not
good I prefer a 4e ounce in my hand I
try and talk about all those weird
glands who could pull out all the smells
and their hairs as well if you're 13
years then you going through hell it's
news to me I hit puberty I was 5 for 1
then I grew to be 6 3 actually is 6 2 I
lied to make sure that the line of the
last one ride oh hey puberty
yeah you got a thank you spend five
hours every day having wiped this
amazing you start coming on the double
glazing
I am sorry Guetta was so brazen I was so
hyped up I was inviting all the ladies
on a date
say coming skydiving I went so high I
was scared to speak my balls ain't
dropped so I spoke with the squeak it
went kinda high when my voice broke I'll
be right in to the skydiving bike no
spokes cuz I'm brave
I like to take a parachute with me and
jump off here Oh exciting I won't do a
stunt cuz I'm scared on the speaker was
it terrifying for you what was he easier
probably you've got a chiseled jawline
sir lookin like you went puberty before
anybody heard you were diving around
gettin no scare the last thing did you
know that when you're up there so high a
problem that you can meet is you get
deep vein thrombosis DVT so you get no
circulation in your lower legs mate you
need to make sure they circulate that
blood real good no go to hell
if you don't get the platelets and those
blood cells and the worst one I get my
doctor close he says Chris have you
noticed you've got large toes I'm loud
please talk to me this is new news
admittedly I wear absolutely massive
shoe size 13 what is about it frustrates
me is cuz I've got very poor blood
circulation see
[Applause]